go see
dude I'd hired it in the future man oh
man oh I gotta turn that [ __ ] on
no so loud
you ever met this guy oh I'm the dumble
you can't argue there's something about
me you have no idea
[Music]
yeah oh oh the chicks dig that guy yeah
but isn't he having kids and [ __ ] with
other people yeah but he's not with them
no no but he was supposed to be at the
time he was you know sweetheart
it's not like I'm with that woman how
about Tom Brady like Tom Brady's wife is
like upset and I was thinking to myself
she's the second supermodel he's gotten
pregnant you know that oh yeah no I
didn't know that you know she makes it
but also she makes more money than I
don't know about more no she does can't
be more oh you don't know sports right
I'll take it from here to put dude his
endorsements and [ __ ] there's no way I I
find that hard to believe Nick bring it
up no the only reason why I think at a
time she did oh and I think recently
with tb12 and all that stuff and the 300
million he just signed with Fox yeah and
also she's what 45 at this point like
all you guys are what oh you're hating
I'm not hating models make a lot of
money when they're 20 something uh the
former net worth of 400 million well Tom
Brady's estimated worth around 250
million
she owns like part of [ __ ] Victoria
she's such a beast wow
she's like mad at him well she's mad
because he decided to play football I
know but let's say she decides to leave
him I think he'll be oh yeah nah but
it's but it's sad though I don't have
sad it is kind of sad when you see that
y'all wow yeah but he still did it
no I don't know I know I know I mean
play football yeah he still did it oh
come on yeah dude she was straight up
like I I don't want what she Brazilian I
don't want you to [ __ ] do another
thing please or I will leave and he goes
like this
that's what I would have done but I
think after the first game though he was
I think he was thinking about it I think
when he got hit a couple times he was
like oh [ __ ] I'm 45. yeah and then
they're like my kids is mad at me like
this isn't as fun anymore but also he's
probably like you know what you signed
up for she's like yeah [ __ ] I thought
you're gonna do a normal career 10 years
you've been in this [ __ ] for 30 years
you're too good you're 45. stop taking
your bionic [ __ ] whatever you're
eating he just drinks uh avocado shakes
and [ __ ]
he looks weathered though it looks like
it's taking its toes I gotta tell you I
completely disagree everyone's making
fun of her I think he looks absolutely
fantastic really he looks like he's on
Castaway no he looks like Nick when he
lost weight but we're just used to
seeing him all beefed up he looks great
he looks like a guy walking he'd be like
wow that guy's [ __ ] answer me he has
my face on the left there so that's a
shame yeah his face is very small oh he
looks great it's just rapidly changing
people like think he might be doing
cosmetic surgery like the chin double
just keeps bigger and no no I think he's
doing cosmetic surgery I think he's such
a Savage with like his health and
fitness he's trying all sorts of [ __ ]
he's probably putting iguana blood in
his [ __ ] eyes you know what I'm
saying iguana blood in my eyes you heard
that in your eyes what do you mean oh
yeah what do you mean in your eyes you
can see better you put it in your eyes
people do do that that's why they came
to my
you know it's funny you mentioned
eyesight yeah that's good for your
eyesight I'll tell you what I'll be
putting iguana blood in my eyes in
Boston you saw me I beat you do it
Boston
look at me
Boston baby boy merch it's hilarious
you're talking about us just iguanas
wait are you when's this one come out
Thursday yes Oxnard California I'll be
there uh two shows on Saturday Peoria
Illinois October 7th big place uh no
Peoria nope okay well we'll see when I
get there Raleigh North Carolina October
21st Savannah Georgia October 22nd Tempe
Arizona Denver Cheyenne Boston Albany
Lakeland and Jacksonville Florida more
dates coming got A Sneak Peek we're
gonna do some [ __ ] New York Chicago
[ __ ] next next month dude I was in
Stockton um
and uh Oakland too right yeah have you
ever played Stockton anybody here I've
always wanted to it is it was the show
was awesome and the crowd was [ __ ]
awesome the place is absolutely nothing
dude there's just be like like buildings
it I was talking about on stage making
fun of it it's like Minecraft dude it's
just you you you you can't go in the
buildings they're all boarded up or it's
like a Mexican restaurant that closes at
1pm oh it's like a fake City dude it's
like North Korea it's unbelievable bro
it's like a coffee shop it's
unbelievable that's close by the way
Ontario Improv uh in October and Colusa
Casino and guys check me out daily on
Eric Griffin gaming on Twitch yeah so if
you want to hit me up on Twitch I will
be in there you to answer all your
questions how's that new PlayStation
working Daddy how's that news
stations nope they make Stockton look
way better than it is they always do
well drone makes anything look lit air
Griffin gaming twitch so do Eric in
gaming and then also then go to Boston
then go see Chris and Colusa Casino
Ontario no problem all right yeah what
are we doing
um yeah but Stockton and Oakland you
played Oakland yeah I played in Oakland
Oakland's kind of one of those weird uh
cities because it's not really a comedy
town right like you just play San
Francisco I guess it's more of a black
comment down it's huge for uh black guys
yeah but yeah I think it's better yeah
there's a club down in Oakland really
yeah some dudes who killed down there
yeah I don't know a club in Oakland I
got an off for them it was like oh
really he's like you gotta be pretty PC
with this I don't know show audience
yeah I have heartbeats that didn't
matter really he's like yeah no they do
um you're not black so we can't send you
that I did so I did go you should go so
I did
um Oakland the theater there and it was
like the four blocks that the theater
was in it was beautiful awesome like
they were gonna gentle time nearby there
yeah they were going to gentrify Oakland
and then like covet happened and then
it's like just they gave up yeah they
gave up we'll get to it they just go
okay we succumb and like now it's like
dude there were seven drive-bys in the
past two days I was there and my my tour
manager was like your merch was it yeah
for my merch yeah we want that exclusive
[ __ ]
and uh oops oops and um thick boy [ __ ]
you Chris yeah so uh so my tour manager
was like all right so Stockton is really
bad we're gonna go from
Stockton We're not gonna stay in
Stockton because it's a bad area we're
gonna drive after the show to Oakland
and stay in Oakland it's a much better
area so I'm like okay great dude and my
tour manager told me when we got to
Stockton he said you know I I know we
weren't going to stay in Stockton and
the car set up to go to Oakland but when
we go to Oakland I'm going to run in and
get your keys and then come back and
give it to you so you could just go in
the hotel I'm like why why can't I just
go check in he was like there's been
seven drive-bys in the past two days in
Oakland
and I'm like and we're going there extra
time dude seven drive-bys in two days
yeah but but that's that's North that's
Oakland I just goes a [ __ ] show they got
rid of the D it's bad San Francisco
I've told you this the first time I went
to San Francisco I was so excited to go
to San Francisco these are the things I
saw in San Francisco and this is not a
lie I saw uh a guy [ __ ] in between
two mailboxes yeah I like that yeah that
that
get a thick Boy shirt yeah
two guys [ __ ] in the street okay in
the actual Street two guys [ __ ] with
their pants like just
um two different people in their cars
alone Crying by themselves
um sounds fantastic okay I saw another
guy uh break out of it checks cash place
like they were trying to keep them in
there he broke out and slammed the door
the whole side shattered and came down
so another guy get hit by a bus this was
all the first weekend dude I was there
and it was and it was freezing in in
August dude my first time up in San
Francisco Brian tells me how great it is
like doing stand up at The Cobbs we're
walking down the street dude just no
shirt not just a [ __ ] ring
oh he's like it's not frowned upon him
no he has a [ __ ] ring on dude he's like
yeah so that's the part that bugged you
oh no no no not at all I went back
several times
I gave him free merch tickets dude I
feel like
he asked you about it again you know
yeah they go like hey man how's this
club or how's this place to me it's
never about the actual
you know theater or Club it's always
about where am I staying and what is
there to do because what are you at this
club or theater for what two three hours
a day and then the other 21 hours you're
at wherever yeah see I disagree I just
give a flying [ __ ] about the audience
the crowd if the crowd's lit I don't I
don't care if my hotel is in a crowd
will follow you it's gonna be fine but
like I just was in Milwaukee yeah you
know and then where the club is it's not
even in Milwaukee it's in Brooks field
like outside yeah yeah
right what is it called Brookfield
you're close but that's mix and Jeffrey
Dahmer's tommygrounds right how the [ __ ]
do you know by the way he's from there
have you oh yeah
most impressive serial killer of all
time
oh dudes he's from American Horror Story
is that [ __ ] Versace one did you see
that Versace one he did oh yes hold on
she was yes
2019 yeah no that was fun yeah that was
fun and then the OJ one came before that
too right cool click OJ one was terrible
but anyway you're so far off I'm so good
I'm staying across a highway yeah and
there's nothing yeah I know well you
pick the hotel dad I didn't that's a
problem
by the way Green Bay was playing right
so I couldn't really [ __ ] I couldn't
rent a car because they were all right
they were all rented and they were like
and then the lady's going like this well
we have an SUV but it's like 200 a day
you know like she was clearly price
gouging oh you know what I mean she's
like oh I can go down to six and I was
like I just wanted to be like it's
Packer season baby it's popping but that
Jeffrey Dahmer series dog let me explain
it you know serial killers too this is
well made which the actor and it's so
good he's from American Horror Story too
yeah yeah but that's why he's the most
impressive serial killer of all time I
know you like serial killers as much as
I do like them but I mean the posters
they're interesting yeah yeah I have a
yeah whatever I dig them but Jeffrey
Dahmer is the most impressive because he
killed all these dudes 17 on record but
there's way more than that yeah 17
hammered hammered because he could only
kill when he's drunk because he couldn't
deal with it if he was a hammered so
they said he would consume like 36 pairs
a day and kill just men too all these
other [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah killing women and kids nah dude
we're talking about dudes gay dudes
strong gay he would have killed you 100
he would have killed you drunken [ __ ]
and then someone like oh dude you know I
know he looks gay you know he wasn't gay
but wait Dahmer was gay
he [ __ ] did he [ __ ] guys it's not by
himself oh you yeah so I thought you're
saying he wasn't gay no super good yeah
it's really shot well well Ryan Murphy
[ __ ] it's uh some of Ryan Murphy [ __ ] is
amazing this is so creepy everyone looks
spot onto Jefferson
but he would have turned you gay for
sure he would have made you a twink by
the way
a thick boy a thick boy come here the
only joke I'm a kiss imma kiss you
oh man you know let's take a break
what do you think we take a break uh
let's take a freaking break let's take a
break I'll tell you what I'm taking a
break in Boston this Thursday Friday
Saturday buddy okay I'm in San Jose oh
did you not oh you're talking about
different breaks yeah I'm talking about
a different break here because the NFL
action is in full swing here at
DraftKings sports book and you're a big
NFL guy well it's a Well what I like
about it is they're the official sports
betting partner of the NFL dude we
talking touchdowns big plays bigger wins
daddy right the new customers can bet
just five dollars on an NFL team to win
and get now let me just say this now you
bet five dollars you think well maybe
I'll get ten dollars but here you get
200 in free bets if they win and if
that's not enough for you everyone can
boost their winnings with DraftKings
stepped up same game parlays right now
for every leg you add you can boost your
winnings up to 100 with payouts bigger
than ever why bet on football anywhere
else if you ain't using DraftKings you
ain't
[ __ ] yeah yeah and then look to make
things even sweeter you can throw down
on stepped up same game parlays once per
game day all season long like I said
throw down yeah
dude throw down download DraftKings
Sportsbook app right now use promo code
Kats to get 200 in free bets if your
team wins when you place a five dollar
bet on any football game that's code
k-a-t-s only a draftking Sportsbook an
official Sports button partner the NFL
minimum age eligibility restriction
Supply C show notes for details Drafting
and I do want to say I want to shout out
to all the ladies that watch I have your
back so don't worry oh no
I'm pissed off all week let me tell you
something this [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] I
posted on the Goddamn point of this
thing I post a [ __ ] clip from this
show on my Instagram talking about this
[ __ ] Okay look dude okay look
you know what let's just [ __ ] take it
back a little bit all right so I said I
was brought up a buddy of mine that said
he got a vasectomy and I said I don't
know if I would get a vasectomy and then
this [ __ ] chimes in with his
[ __ ] white night [ __ ] dude always
he's ha he's not even white I'm here for
you ladies
dude he came in there with a Kamala hair
shirt
I will advocate for you
while these two
what I said was I wouldn't get a
vasectomy and now this guy's like well
it's not natural for the girl to take a
pill and this and that and it [ __ ] up
their bodies
Khan is not natural pull it out it's a
natural man you're supposed to split
inside yeah and now I'm [ __ ] now I'm
now I'm the [ __ ] on the thing
that was like oh Chris is perpetuated
I'm infatuated [ __ ] oh I am
I care if you're gonna get me in more
trouble dude all right dude I don't know
what I said but I I don't know what I
said look at this [ __ ] look at this [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] baby Eric that [ __ ]
was so sexy
really then [ __ ] them ah yeah I said can
I get a win can I get a win look at this
hold on go up go up look at these
comments Eric has some dollars just wait
until y'all have daughter she doesn't
have I I dude you think the Red River
emotions are crazy Linda Blair has
nothing they're acting like I said every
woman on the planet should be on birth
control dude I don't even I don't even
give a [ __ ] if your birth control or not
bro I pull out if I want man I'm not one
of those guys that's like Mom but it
feels too good dude I pull out them way
back dude I'm in the other room when I I
go baby give me a second I go I make a
sandwich
I'm not off I mean this [ __ ] you get
in the car you're gonna drive you're
gonna coffee me I said you order can I
get four shots can I can I get four
shots of
espresso and
that's amazing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey hey
I love people that take all this stuff
serious you're so correct man oh man I
got a message from someone too I sent it
to Chris it was just so funny I
unfollowed Chris
I bet I'm better at pulling out than you
are
you have a kid though Eric might be
pretty nice with it yeah it could be
yeah yeah here's what I told Chris the
issue that happened is it's you he was
making a funny joke I think you're a
little [ __ ] monologue was like the
the massage
yeah
I like to Stow the fire hey you know
what's called
comedy podcast I know well I know but
these [ __ ] act like we're on
NPR and [ __ ] it's a TED Talk How You
Gonna tune in a comedy show hey I can't
energy that's why I'm here you bring
that Ted Talk energy
sometimes you got sometimes I gotta
bring a little
but who would tune into this and be like
oh they made a great point on birth
control today some people they did
that's why dumb people dumb people
you guys both get me in trouble this
guy's getting serious and then you're
[ __ ] you know what I mean I like to
because I like to uh
okay what's this about all right what's
up oh this kid's [ __ ] suited and
booted
it's awesome
it's pretty lit
that's funny and he's good bro
gang gang
oh don't laugh
Little Brian Deegan yeah it's good to do
in the graphics
I kind of wanted to see it go a little
faster it was a big build up like kids
it would have been dope if it was like
but that's cool
though yeah it's dope
um Fearless kid it's gonna just he has a
great life ahead I think about the [ __ ]
like that back when we were kids it's
like
we had to Pedal you know and my big
wheel it's like you know what I mean I
had to like do this you never drive it
on what I'm saying I had to do this on
the big wheels it had the one big wheel
in the front yeah and there were plastic
stupid face this is how I had to I had
to be like this or I had a green machine
you remember a green machine the green
machine was the one that they had like
that
yeah the green machine was like you had
this and you had to pedal and then you
had to turn like this so it'd be like
right left I mean that's like in a
banana bike you have a banana sea bike
yeah there you go yeah well I thought
that's the best way to do wheelies [ __ ]
yeah I had to be out I had to go outside
man I didn't have I grew up I had no
internet okay I didn't have crazy is
that yeah this is bananas I actually
have to go play hide and seek I used to
play football on with grass and cement I
had I used to have to uh you know we
played baseball with uh with tennis
balls in our neighborhood
[ __ ] bro you go you go I have to
play hide and seek he goes great game
[Laughter]
that's how you stay hidden you know what
I mean we couldn't be in the dryer it's
on no no one played Red Rover Red Rover
yeah you're too big I'm not this is even
a fat joke you're too big for Red Rover
well Red River where is the Red Rover
everyone holds hands and there's two
teams there's like a long string of
people on each side and they go Red
Rover Red Rover send Eric right over and
Eric has to break the grip oh the kid
was like too big or fat he was like no
well you couldn't do that either oh dude
I would [ __ ] I was a wedge Buster bro I
would [ __ ] like crazy kids up yeah
yeah no
um I play Red Rover and uh I played
um what is this the Red Rover
championships holy [ __ ] oh there's
there's Brandon right there okay serious
I like how they all live oh here it
comes he's so slow
oh there's got to be a sketch yes damn
it so that's what it I don't remember it
being that that seems like you can't
play that anymore it might be I never
played no you can't even play dodgeball
you can't play smear the queer that
seems like a weird white game
no I play with all black guys all black
guys
was fun
yeah you can't trust anybody now
nobody's gonna stay like Chris
couldn't trust Chris is the kind of kid
you'd be like you're you know free
you're Frozen and you'd be like I'm not
frozen yeah yeah yeah you're right
you're 100 right stupid you don't have
powers you guys never played 500 what
about 500. anyone else have a regular
[ __ ] childhood we played the same
games 500 is there's just a bunch of
people trying to catch it the thrower
throws it up you guys played the same
game yeah and then you're drinking a
problem drinking
Oh no I got it no there we go I guess he
might be right yeah you know what Young
Young
both things can be true they can be
young and also
so yeah Dahmer's like yeah it's just
crazy there was no internet like I
remember when it started and there was
just no internet before I was like 16
just none you know but also with the
internet and like kids and stuff these
days it's on the parents dude my kids
only get their iPads on the weekends
yeah yeah they only get it Saturday
morning for an hour and other than that
they don't get it back Kristen got up
she was like I don't want to get him an
iPad you know I mean he's [ __ ] two
but like she got him like a a game pad
which is much better because like he
just goes to play games and like can't
watch movies on it and [ __ ] and he plays
it very [ __ ] sparingly but like if
you give a kid a whole iPad I feel like
both my kids have iPads no they can't do
anything on the weekend you can regulate
so like YouTube kids only his playlist
for his music oh it's only music I
download from the movies only I download
for them right you don't have the code
to get in downloading yeah yeah
he got it yeah the two-year-old two
years
like putting the code in right in front
of them thick boy yeah yeah yeah
no but I mean I I do feel like this is a
whole different you know how kids are
growing up I think they don't have good
interpersonal skills that's on the
parents you know what I mean yeah yeah
for the most part yes I agree unless you
get a Dahmer type I mean that's not all
the parents fault it's not the parents
fault at all it's not the parent's
father it's a lot I got my black belt
and Dahmer bro it's um he's one of the
rare that his parents especially growing
up they would fight like anybody's
[ __ ] parents my parents got divorced
a drug addict some [ __ ] no no she left
him when he was 18. nature
he called the he had to call the
ambulance for his mom when she was a
fake this is no she had some issues
whose mom didn't am I right but also he
grew up pretty normal but he even said
like when they were interviewing him
he's in the real interviews I don't know
if they talk about on the show maybe a
little bit they alluded to it but he was
like I was born like this so when he got
caught he's like you guys need to kill
me now there's no help there's nothing
to do I've felt this way since I was
[ __ ] it was crazy though he was so
brazen
just look this [ __ ] had heads in
his refrigerator well that's pretty you
know you can't do that dude he was in an
apartment with neighbors killing people
and it smelled like [ __ ] yeah he just
had blackheads in his refrigerator just
kind of like they were just really
creepy scene man it's just like you know
the refrigerator opens he's grabbing a
beer and they can't you see a heads
underneath and you're just kind of like
oh [ __ ] this one that's how [ __ ] up it
was so we're literally wired to uh hate
the smell of rotting bodies it's not
normal yeah yeah because he couldn't
smell it Tammy was normal he's like Oh I
thought it was a new Camelot he had it
and everyone else that smells like [ __ ]
of acid in his place that he was you
know it's like he was like doing
everything to get caught crazy just
everybody he was like Hey I'm killing
[ __ ] out of here yeah that's
basically what he did they had so many
opportunities to kill him like the
Milwaukee Police [ __ ] up royally they
caught that one 14 year old gay dude he
escaped the house and the cop was like
hold on what's going on here the kid's
all drugged up and then Dominic they
brought him back to dahmers and Dahmer's
like oh yeah that's my boyfriend yeah
you know the neighbor was like dude he's
14 like that's not his boyfriend like
he's clearly [ __ ] he looks young yeah
and then Dahmer said cool let me drill
into your head son that's what he did
you you know what it's funny crazy about
that as they played like this is the
real cop call The Neighbors calling the
cops like that seems like a child in the
cops are like ma'am it was his boyfriend
he looked into it you know you know what
I mean it's just like God damn they use
the real thing in the show yeah yeah the
first body ever they probably the first
body he ever killed he had in the back
of his [ __ ] car not in the trunk in
the back car gets pulled over for
drinking and driving the cop's like
what's in the back he's like oh those
are leaves I can't sleep at night so I
like to rake the leaves so those are
just leaves and he goes oh I'm gonna
give you a pass son because you're young
and he's like swerving all over Dude wow
man what the [ __ ] why privilege am I
right I don't know about that just dumb
cops but uh all right we'll take their
time in history it was a white privilege
well it was but also how privilege
that's you're come on bro he's got a
body in the back well you know dude with
these uh yeah if it was a black guy that
would have been like let me see the lady
I don't care about that I'm Charming and
persuasive thank you yes white people
racist no I'm saying not all of us yeah
I know I know just a few like Ted Bundy
like you know what I mean Hello office
or nice nice outfit listen I yeah
those leaves smell like a dead no Chris
is a serial killer wants to he gets bad
a cop he just you know he looks at the
imaginary camera
that'd be the nickname would be the oops
killer
I use it on my stream Eric Griffin
gaming
um all right so let's see what's up with
this dude we've had this guy before
right no I don't think I don't think so
what up cats crew it's your friend Jose
from the Bay Area
[Music]
this is like me and Blake Griffin had a
baby
you're unfilled with your thoughts
uh I'll let Nick pull up the video and
yeah I love the show guys uh thanks for
everything you do gang gang buzz buzz
soaroo
oh not bad not bad a little Harmony
going on yeah he didn't mean to though
yeah so so this teacher I didn't know
this I've talked about this on my
podcast lifeline and I have more to say
about it so go ahead so we brought up on
my other podcast finding the kid uh 10
years in running that big deal you got
on there and get your start there but
yeah yeah
that's how I popped dude we've launched
so many [ __ ] people it's stupid
anyway so um when we when we when we
played this we played this I literally I
I thought it was real this is out of
control I did too and then you know
Brian's 77 years old right Brian was
like no this she's this guy is showing
how ridiculous yeah which is great
titties and I was like no this is
[ __ ] and then apparently fans like
no dude it's all yeah he's far right
like last year was like oh the skin out
of hand and then now that just turned
into the dumbest thing to the greatest
thing yes
it's hilarious oh so this guy's just
making fun of them he almost got shot
apparently he almost got fired for toxic
masculinity and he says okay then I'm a
woman and I'm getting big fake titties
and now he's like what this is okay you
say this that's hilarious well that's
what the school board they go what can
we do and he's like yeah that's how
ridiculous dude the nipples are like
Pokemon it's all the way down
and you know what do you know what you
know what the best thing about all this
is he's like the best teacher in the
school kids love his class well of
course creative no he's smart as [ __ ]
and it's also it'd be hilarious as a
[ __ ] middle school or high school to
see just tits but what I'm saying is
this is things outside the box you know
you know it's I saw it I saw I saw a lot
of people say uh their problem with it
was that uh she didn't have her hair in
a pony using that song
that's no no shopping don't worry about
her [ __ ] song those tits yeah well I
wouldn't hurt are prosthetic right but
the titties are like the nipples like
poke out it's so ridiculous it's so
funny I thought it was real and on
Lifeline when I was talking about it
because I was like oh this this is
ridiculous and I didn't know it was in
Canada at the time which is like super
right but this guy is doing it to I mean
now I think it's the [ __ ] phone now
he's my hero yeah yeah see you and I are
the same you were the same buddy yeah
except I mean there's a weight
difference but yeah
well there's a white difference too
because you're not kidding anybody
you're a little Mexican but yeah or
Native American whatever it is bro your
hair bro it's good hair yeah but it's
just not white hair so what was he like
what was the the reason why he wanted to
do this but did something happen yeah
they threatened him because he was being
too toxic I don't know what that is he
was like far right so he was like I'm
sorry the shop teacher with the electric
saw was being masculine masculine yeah
yeah he's a little too manly and he's
like and they're like we're gonna have
to fight to keep this up he's like say
less I'm gonna come back next week I'm a
woman now you can't say [ __ ] on these
big fake tits imagine telling a [ __ ]
Canadian man that is like Cuts wood and
makes [ __ ] and like he's being too much
of a guy like that's what a man is you
see these [ __ ] and you go to
Canada especially you go north I don't
know where it was I don't think it's a
Wilderness Area my God bro they're all
like six eight the nicest dudes ever and
just making their own Furniture yeah and
killing boars the one of the roughest
shows I've ever done is in a little town
called Prince Albert wow in Canada and
it's like first of all the place stinks
because it's like a paper mill and
there's like six or seven prisons and I
did this show and it was like a in a bar
above the bar in this weird room and it
was just combat comedy man you're just
kind of like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you know I'm
just like you know
and then everybody's like talking and
they're just like comic you know and
then after the show yeah I'm done and
I'm just like I get through this yeah
yeah and then a group of dudes who were
being the worst they're like yeah
comedian come over here I get over there
they're all cops that's that's actually
really North for Canada even though it
looked like it was South yeah super
North yeah because there's nothing up
there yeah like that's this North as it
goes up I mean there's like five people
you had to take a bus from Saskatoon oh
oh I've done I've done that not not
there but I've done that I was in North
Battleford yeah you have to take a bus
like there's no like you know it sounds
like places in Game of Thrones yeah no
[ __ ] dude I was in I've never heard of
any I got to North Battleford okay North
Battleford and the [ __ ] guy
the guy [ __ ] there at the
um Hotel I was saying that that was
right next to the casino I was playing
uh he was like how long have you been
town for and I was like I leave
tomorrow thank God and he was like oh
all right I was gonna bring you ice
fishing and I was like
no you were never
oh I'd be down for that and then I was
like I know you're thinking it's cold
but it's actually really hot in those
Huts yeah because you're like
yeah none of this matter
so do you have you watched anything I've
ever done
I will be outside of that area and I'll
be gone
sometimes you get to a city like that
you're just like what am I doing here I
know I know and that was combat comedy
too yeah
um and as a matter of fact the opener
who was I showed up and they got some
local opener
he was like so uh you're um what's the
deal with uh what do you do out there
and I was like uh I don't know I just
kind of get out there and do my set he
was like oh and
I he opens for me
I do my set and I come back and he's
sitting there
and he says oh I know who you are I
thought you were a musician
[Laughter]
and I'm like this is a
this is a comedy show I'm the headlight
yeah he was like I thought you were
gonna go out there and do music they
booked the wrong guy they thought they
had a singer like yeah
[Laughter]
guy from
um Foo Fighters he loves ice fishing
dude yes yes but some of those weird
towns when the people like Oh Come do
this and you do it it's fun oh yeah oh
yeah like I was in uh can somewhere in
Kentucky this dude comes to meet and
greet like straight up Real McCoy horse
farmer so you boys gotta come to my
horse farm yeah and I was like yeah
there's nothing else dude yeah you can
do let's [ __ ] do it literally two
hour drive into the sticks at Kentucky
and the boys we get there it is like a
movie it was like a [ __ ] Jordan Peele
movie it was just white horses oh wow
all white horses just white horses
that's cool tons of them just White
Horse yeah dude it was so weird it was
so [ __ ] weird name
just so weird well I don't know and then
Force Farms they give you whiskey and
bourbon to sit on like nice [ __ ] I
didn't know that nice and we're just
kidding swishy bet you could bring up
Trump there huh oh he probably would
have to leave early to rate the capital
he probably raid the cap on one of those
white horses all right well so I wonder
what's I wonder if we can if they're
gonna be updates on what what's going on
with that guy different time but there's
Brandon and a horse yeah there will be
updates now that horse that hurt my
feelings because I was in Montana my
family and they go they bring out
everybody's horses oh man uh then he
goes bring out the fridge wow that's
funny the fridge and then this [ __ ]
they're like come on and I'm like what
the [ __ ] and this giant [ __ ] horse
comes out
I was fat ashamed right on my vacation
well other that are the horse going to
come out looking like a [ __ ] you yeah
you're gonna Dent that [ __ ] I've
been on a horse in Saudi Arabia oh wow
that's the light Flags yeah really Jesus
Christ yeah you could be a local people
think you're local yeah some [ __ ] went
down for sure
[Laughter]
that's why I always say like being
multi-ethnic
you know it's like what'd he says
you can't do good for the country unless
you're alive so yeah whatever it takes
wow Nick always you're like a shot
teacher always thinking outside the box
crew it's Alex at Giant Financial I had
him recovering from a surgery but as you
can see behind me I have an old Call of
Duty poster and I was wondering can't
get her sting it Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 that is coming out in a few
weeks beta starts up pretty soon I don't
know what do you guys think might be
more of a question for Eric and Chris
who knows also Eric I know you remember
when I gave you that sniper tip and you
hit that dirty shot gang gang buzz buzz
I bet that dude is nice on that game
yeah he also has Mark Harley's voice
yeah it's deep voice that's Mark
Harley's a huge compliment yeah yeah
just a back throat of [ __ ]
I've played the beta the called new the
new one is that like a sample or what
yeah it just means like the game comes
out early so they're still doing testing
yeah yeah it's very buggy but if you're
a fan of uh Battlefield the battlefield
series then you're gonna like this
because this it's a slower game the
shooting mechanics are different it's
not the same as uh the original I was
never I I played Call of Duty 2 the
[ __ ] World War II one I think yeah
and then after that I just stopped
because yeah why are you not gaming
anymore I don't know I told him it's not
I talked about the same thing it's not
his name yeah I do kind of like it but
no it's so fun
I do like it I like the idea of it like
I want everyone to know like I like
video games but I just don't have the
time well there's that it does you got
to play for like a long time to get good
and um I don't know man
it is fun though so I don't really get
why I don't do it because you know what
are you gonna do to get home and you got
whatever two hours with your kid before
he goes Ben you're [ __ ] on the sticks
like a [ __ ] crazy but also as opposed
to say drinking whiskey at night
but but also you can make money doing it
so that's another thing that's like yeah
I could make money do it but I just
don't I don't know hey you need more
money
that's a good point no I don't know I
like video game that [ __ ] Spider-Man
game was the [ __ ] you play that one yeah
[ __ ] fun and Red Dead Redemption too
have you did you play that what really I
thought it was gay too yeah
I feel like that would be a good way for
him to start because it's got horses the
ranch and white horse
uh Metal Gear Solid oh God Metal Gear
solids
what about Twisted Metal did they make
that again I'm in yeah but they'd have
to make GoldenEye [ __ ] shitty like
that again yeah
I think they are actually coming out
with a new whoever picked odd job you're
like [ __ ] cheater
and don't people twitch old games like
he could go on and play Twisted Metal
too and people would love that really I
like oh I like open world games though
yeah I don't like games where you have
to do like a mission and you can't go
wherever you want to go but that's uh
red dead but no that's all right the
best game one of the best games ever was
Batman Arkham Knight I just downloaded
that here's how much I don't play video
games I downloaded it a month ago I
didn't play it that game I haven't
played oh you could play on the road
right a lot of places
if you have a bus then then oh yeah but
I don't like being on a bus plus we talk
about I have a whole kit I know but you
gotta explain it yeah I carry it on it's
carry it on yeah
it's like a self-contained unit from
this company called games g-a-e-m-s you
know Eric's married [ __ ] Xbox yeah
well I remember when I first excuse me
when I was first dating Rachel you know
and and I'm I'm getting my game system
ready to go right and she's like you've
played video games on the road bro she's
gonna like it she knows exactly who you
are though but I feel like this I go
well normally I would try to chase hoes
oh and she goes like this where's your
controller
you need anything else yeah I was like
this is what I do now yeah I'm in my
hotel room going you know on Twitter you
can watch me whatever you can watch it
yeah she gets a notification when I go
online you know what I mean not to
mention that you know she she could
track me with her phone you should make
it so your your notification because you
can make it whatever you want it's like
Eric is not getting hoes yes
yeah you know what I mean so it's like
you know it's like but I I enjoy it so
I'm in my I love when I go on the road
because now it's like I don't have to
worry about like trying to figure out
what I'm gonna do I'm just sitting in my
room I'm you know I'm going I'll go eat
I'll try to go down to the gym and get
on the get on the treadmill for like
[ __ ] 20 minutes there you go bro
I love that [ __ ]
uh I used to a lot like I was a big
Madden guy Metal Gear Solid was one of
my favorite games as well that's what it
is
metal seal who knows but that's one of
the best of all time but yeah it was a
time thing and people like you said
people get so good it's not fun unless
you commit that's another thing yeah
it's like this guy goes to the nose
meetings with Chris oh yeah I love big
noses yeah this is bonjour and I got a
king in her stinging I was watching this
video
termites for protein
and so the king understanding it is
eating termites for protein me
personally I can't because we got to get
rid of those little suckers any way we
can
wow he was a real termite problem he
does so did this one
and so did this one but this time it
almost fell on my son okay
all day he did this all day
I like how hours went by and he was like
wait I gotta do the thing and this is
the one he sent
all the cuts I took them all day
by the way this is going to be the
future I feel like hot chicks he might
be 10 years away from Like There's No
More Cows they're not oh yeah you know
you wish chicks you think chicks can be
doing this [ __ ] that's what you're
saying no I'm saying we're gonna be
eating bugs oh they've tried it before
they've tried about like five years ago
tried a big grasshopper [ __ ] not just
those are termite what is that yeah it's
a termite nest
look at this look at this look at this
you're just gonna lick them like an
anteater
oh he got that's a sexy ass anteater
yeah but see this is what I'm saying
though this is this is not fair because
you like yeah you need like a troll or a
monster he's gonna be a hero no no no no
I'm saying what I'm saying guys like soy
milk when you do this when she's doing
it it don't matter she could be eating
dookie and we're gonna be like oh maybe
this is gonna be a new thing yeah yeah
I'm just saying it's like the the the
the packaging like the the messenger
yeah show us the warlocks yeah I like
that yeah I want to see a warlock the
messenger met changes the message yeah
yeah you know what I mean yeah wow
that's [ __ ] interesting Alex Jones
thinks the world economic Forum wants us
to eat bugs to get our protein from it
because it has chitin in the uh
exoskeletons docile yeah he's right oh
man
anyone is listening to Alex Jones ever
again you know what are we talking about
bro
I said well who why aren't they pushing
he said they try died I said who and he
said damn
that's all conspiracy guys do yeah yeah
but who is it like come on dude you know
oh no I don't I'm literally
which was all about they they say right
right you know is there a website they
say.com there should be yeah somebody
should start they say.com because that's
when she gets all the information 50 of
when women say that that means Oprah by
the way no no need to tick tock ah okay
so you're oh yeah that's old school was
Oprah now it's back to Alex Jones the
problem with Alex Jones not the prom but
the the issue is some of the [ __ ] he
says he was right on
some of he's completely off but the
people if you're a fan of them you know
the stuff they got right they're like
yeah but look at this I'm like right I
know but he got all this wrong but
you're gonna be right Adventure painter
yeah exactly exactly I have a few of his
pieces and you know no he wasn't good
enough otherwise he wouldn't kill all
those people
right right right everybody's got like
some good thing they do know man like
nobody's entirely evil nobody's entirely
yeah but Alex Jones called out the
Epstein Island like 10 years ago really
on Rogan he was like dude there's this
island and this guy Epstein he's doing
all this and I was like that sounds
[ __ ] crazy he's like they bring
celebrities and politicians there and
there's kids well by the but Epstein was
already being investigated and been got
off so many not even before that not
that no but I'm saying everything
everything about him was already there
in the same way everything about Cosby
was already out too it just took
Hannibal Buress was just kind of like
yeah you should Google this and then
everybody started to go oh let me see
and then it just blew up the
information's out there
right so this is then start a conspiracy
podcast Doug I had dinner with Alex
Jones in Austin
yeah I can't imagine what that's like
it's so entertaining it's just it's just
a lot yeah he's so entertaining well he
did yeah he's entertaining for sure I
mean I know but he just went too far and
then well but he wasn't very funny he
really [ __ ] up with the Massachusetts
he literally had to pay for a lot too
yeah all right
what's up with Limp Bizkit any amount of
money that he had to pay would be like a
ridiculous amount of money not for him
yeah how much he makes a month I know no
now what
enough really yeah
but but that's why it was multi-million
you know bigger you know more than
everybody combined in this room a month
easily easily and then including Eric
[Applause]
well we know that's not it because what
happens if same thing happened with
Rogan I'm not comparing comparing Rogue
yeah uh right career to outsources facet
right but what happens is so they you
know they he's on Fox he's on CNN on
msbc he's all over so what happens is a
lot of people who just watch that stuff
go hell he has a piece of [ __ ] right
right right and a ton of people let me
look into this I understand the normal
people let me look in this thing up I
kind of [ __ ] with this guy so it builds
his fan base yeah yeah because his Fan's
already there they still believe in them
they tried to cancel Rogan and then he
got two or three more million
subscribers and then now now you don't
even hear about that [ __ ] anymore no
they can't all the Spotify people who
were like oh we gotta get they were like
they must be like ah
your face
so that's how much he made that's a lot
of money but that was before all that
[ __ ] yes 53 million so so in what an
Infowars filed Banker bankruptcy too but
he didn't it's like restructuring and
stuff so so his his all his shows are on
his website right that he controls his
network but yeah his network but he
doesn't get advertising stuff there he
has his own supplement line like
supplements so what he does is sells
that so that's how you support him
supplements as in like fish Oilers okay
multivitamins just you know a hustle
that stuff's great for conspiracy people
he sells that yeah but then the way even
if they're not in the vitamins like well
we want him to stay on the air we're
gonna buy supplements got it and the
amount of people the Bible's [ __ ] sup
when he told me I was like holy [ __ ]
dude I think there's this flat but
that's why he was that's why he's out
there anyway this is what I think
anybody that somebody perceives is like
well that person weird or crazy or
they're out of pocket or whatever they
think about them
just go to the Forbes list and you'll
know why they're doing it well all these
right wing guys for instance right
Sean Hannity right all these guys they
make like 50 60 75 million dollars a
year right right being like that
Ben Shapiro you know how much Ben
Shapiro when I saw it actually the same
age I was like
you're gonna have me out there being
like you know oh what Obama ruined this
country yeah yeah yeah yeah hey there we
go you're making 80s that but this is my
point this is what I feel like news
shouldn't be for profit because how can
you be biased how can you be unbiased no
if that amount of money is what's the
one people Tucker Carlson is another one
Tucker Carlson makes so much money it's
like yeah if you're gonna make that much
money being that kind of character then
what are we talking about that's why you
know anyways God look at that the other
one jumpers 800 890
000 paid subscribers how much money we
make off patreon now think of his just
just just just think of it just a dollar
just think if it's just a dollar a month
you know what I mean minimum it starts
at ten but I'm just saying it's like a
banana I think about 10. I know bananas
120 million dollars a year correct sir
well they have expenses and to try to
make myself feel better it's a bigger
production so they have a lot of more
employees so it's not about the same for
me I do stand up it's just me I don't
have that many expenses they got like 10
marks you know what I mean yeah yeah
they're all with that crazy hair and
[ __ ] they get 890 000 marks yeah yeah
all right
Eric what up what up Chris what up man
what up chin what up culture corner I
think you call it I got a king for you
casual sex with a [ __ ] that's got a
boyfriend already
um I gotta wake up go there on Wednesday
morning when he leaves for work just to
get sloppy seconds I'm doing it because
I'm a [ __ ] gangster I like to
put my penis inside the vaginas if you
know what I'm saying gang gang buzz buzz
he's a rapper
casual sex with a [ __ ] that's got a
dude already do you have to keep calling
a [ __ ]
I was good I was gonna preference it by
saying this might be the worst person
who's ever submitted
yeah that beard I mean yeah dude I mean
if you're gonna say a guy that sleeps
with a girl this is the guy
yeah but if you're the gang find out
that's the guy [ __ ] your girl on
Wednesday mornings what what's the other
guy like that's what I'm saying man I
wasn't gonna do it all right
I don't know does he work for Dracula I
hope you have a good day
and even Hawkins yeah that's what I'm
saying but not but not with the money
check this out
let's say you're the boyfriend yeah you
just happen to be a fan of king and a
sting and you see this guy and you go oh
I know I don't get this yeah you know
yeah
that guy fixed the pool every Wednesday
yeah you're gonna kind of be like what
like this is like even if the girl sees
this she's got to be like what are you
doing
uh
uh yeah yeah
we're gonna move past that one dude oh
she's cool you're gonna get caught like
Wes's face like that Boston's Boston
Celtics head coach oh this guy Mia doku
yeah well you know what the thing is man
he was sleeping with
the vice president of the team's wife
well that's frowned upon but just in
general there are policies coaches can't
have relationships with anybody on the
roster it doesn't even matter let me put
it that does matter because you can't
fire him for for no no you can't fire
him for infidelity no no I know that's
why they suspended it but they're
looking for a reason to fire him but
here's my point if you find out Nick is
sleeping with your wife yeah he's not
going to be sitting here anymore you
know what I mean why not
producers got to produce and it's a good
producer I'm business first note it and
I get it
today Joanna at home like this noted
for some reason you know he gets a text
I'll be amazing
I guess it's a home baby sounds like
we're in the clear why why they did what
they did because wonder they have to
they can't fire him because he'll be
able to sue for unlawful so they're
trying to figure out what to do but look
at me right now he's never coaching I
disagree yeah and for the Celtics again
interesting and he may never coach again
I disagree but the the other thing is
the Lakers these other these other
owners some gangster billionaire dudes
man I was like for sure but anything
same way to college hired the Verizon
guy that was like they need more black
coaches are they a good coach he took
plenty of black coaches half the league
is black coaches no they're not that's
the problem no no no I mean you think in
the NFL no no I think NBA no the NBA's
got played no they're always crying
about it oh talk about videos never
crying about that man but the the thing
my thing with him is my boy uh who
played in the NBA
um Barnes he was saying Matt Barnes
who's close to situation
you guys oh yeah all the smoke yeah all
the smoke is dope I'd like to see him
trying to stand up but okay but he was
saying like the they did that press
conference and he's like there's way
more to it he's like it's bad yeah yeah
he's like what we're hearing it's not
even well we don't know what the [ __ ]
happened yeah but again so you're
talking about this look they had to have
this press conference so they can say
that they did something because here's
the thing too all the women that were
getting like harassed harassed they're
gonna suit us updates they're gonna Sue
they're gonna get a class action lawsuit
there they can't just fire him because
he's he's already lawyered up because
he's going to be like yeah you fired me
give me my money yeah cause I'm the
contract well it's part of the well you
can't sleep I don't know what happened
right but you can't sleep with people
you work with in the office if that's
what happened then you got to get fired
right and that's what the Celtics say
like we don't condone this type of
behavior but he still has a precedent to
be like well you still got to paint but
see the problem is he's a good coach
that's why there's a fight for it I
think this is about I think it's just
personal I think it's personal I think
he he slept with someone's wife he
shouldn't have you know and they they're
going for him because of that you know
that guy's they got Furious you know
you're the vice president and and you're
you're you know
and you know how you got caught that I
read this article about it like who
knows if it's true or not but like the
on the ring camera yeah I heard about
that too yeah the ring camera what she
was that ring camera he was coming in
like you know he was he came to the
house I sent you the clip watch it and
then and then we'll play or not but
watch it first you're saying this clip
is bad too no he just said because we're
talking about the n-word we all Sting
the n-word yeah
oh he's got right there
oh you found it I can't believe you guys
haven't seen this you had it too Eric he
just sent it to me oh word
it's the ultimate weight for it
[Music]
hello yes sir hey how you doing hey
sorry to bother you I'm Fernando I work
with big energy we're a few doors down
we're in 1845. okay so we do solar
around here we're just coming around
talking about it sorry dude neighbors I
apologize man all right and the guy's
black no yeah
look
look just oh [ __ ] oh my God look at him
watch this watch this should I go back
and should I go back and ask him if he
wants solar panels he knows he's gonna
get a fire yeah I mean whatever oh man
he doesn't know yeah because he doesn't
know this guy has he's filming yeah yeah
but like but that's kind of like because
I was working like yeah he said better
so but people don't look at panel steps
nobody in video videos everything man
this is just like Ray Rice you know what
I'm saying Donald Sterling you know
Donald exactly all that stuff you know
what I mean it's just this you know
that's like like
that's one of those like
he that guy regularly talks like that do
you think okay so this is that was gonna
be my question yeah but that was gonna
be my question he just regularly talks
like that he's probably like when he's
in when he's with his friends or like
you know when he's like yeah man I'm on
this neighborhood talking to all these
you know this is how he talks you know
what I mean like here's the thing too I
think I guess because people were like
people are prejudiced I think people
like when people use the word race
racist right right racism implies to me
when you have power over someone and you
uh you you can change the you could take
money out of their pocket you can stop
them from doing things I don't think
like if there's like like say it's like
autism I think people's racism is on the
Spectrum too sure you know what I'm
saying you know so I I don't I'm not
quick to be like well this dude right
right right right I don't know if this
guy's necessarily like right hateful so
much as he's just like one of these
white guys right right Johnny [ __ ] up
you know what I mean yeah
he had the moment too he was like oh no
but also when he saw the bad guy in his
head said he was saying the n-word and
he's like we're selling maybe solar
panels maybe
neighbors that's you know what I mean
that's not even really that close it's
not that close and it was a hard eel
yeah it wasn't like uh so he's in a
black neighborhood that he like does
this all the time no I think he's
surprised I think he was surprised like
in when the Black answer in his head his
initial reaction was oh that's a ninja
and then he said it out loud yeah maybe
I don't know I don't know I have no idea
that that was that is a that is crazy to
me that that happened what whatever kind
of mistake it is whether it's the oops
my racism is showing or I don't even
know I had a brain aneurysm no matter
what it is it's such a [ __ ] up and so he
needs to be like listen I have CT I
played football in high school for two
years but the thing is is like this is
like you know the fact that you have
footage of it is what makes oh yeah oh
yeah because I'm saying how many moments
do normal people have like that not
talking about race no no no but just
sleeping oh like if you came in here
be like that's crazy but this yeah when
you see it like that oh it's bad I
wouldn't want to have my brain fart
moments recorded on a ring camera no of
course not you know what I mean but it's
like this guy's like you just wanted to
you just take it own it and move on I
heard you got a promotion but
it just sucks that that's a mistake
and
yeah yeah yeah
um all right so I don't know whatever
but yeah who's this guy hey guys it's
your friend Eric from Detroit I got a
debate club for you
um if you have a receding hairline such
as myself
should you keep your hair grown out to
hide it
um I had it long for a while no and I
thought I would look better with short
hair so I buzzed it but now you can tell
them no you can't go man it's fine and
uh like [ __ ] Nick Bosa uh some advice
this is eating at me bring up oh really
Club men with receding hairline keep it
grown out or buzz it okay I wish I knew
how old he was oh wow I know Eric Eric
should I get into this one yeah I know
what you're gonna do no I'm saying
here's the thing is you keep it like
this isn't that bad no it's got going on
but once this starts getting a little
smaller yeah like the LeBron James start
thing then it's got to go and his
forehead isn't like deliaish yeah you
know what I mean so it's not like
shorter yeah if it's if it was longer
than it did but you you're maybe like
two three years away from just shaving
your head but also he has so many uh
yeah you see how LeBron James went on
the left there how stupid that looks his
doesn't look that dumb you yeah well
hold on though the the that guy might
that might be where it ends up that guy
I know but that's when you shave
no no no no no no no I'm saying this
might be it for this guy well they're
saying but in two or three years if it
gets worse you think so oh yeah yeah if
this is gonna keep getting thinner and
thinner and thinner that's what happens
but he's lucky because sometimes you
look like that he has a good head yeah
he's a dying piece so he's an attractive
dude so right I think he'll I think
he'll be fine bald he's got a solid head
wear a wig no I'll get why wigs are cool
this is not a thing he looks good who's
wearing a wig you mean like a toupee yes
oh Martin Jeremy Piven I can keep going
look at that that's a Pittsburgh
Steelers helmet it's Carlos Boozer what
is this you're spray painting yeah but
he was trolling yeah
so I was like that looks dope dude Jimmy
Butler was trolling with his haircut
yeah yeah yeah what is it oh it's so
stupid never seen it he just he just
busted it out uh
it's big ass like dreadlocks oh oh well
yeah I was looking
wow that's not real it no it is real
it's not his real hair right he said it
was he's joking and he keeps saying it's
not extensions I think it is extension
it's funny you can't grow your hair yeah
that fast no way because he had that
haircut in the playhouse yeah yeah but
this guy's gonna be fine you know yeah
because the problem is we have an ugly
face then your ugly head he's dying
piece dude hey y'all my name's Ashley
I'm calling from Odessa Texas love the
show I think y'all are [ __ ] hilarious
I think it's so funny when you can hear
Nick giggling in the background that
sends me every time even though I'm
already laughing that just like does it
for me I have a king or sing it for you
contacts glasses or eye Lasik I had the
surgery a couple months ago the best
choice I've ever made in my life feels
good being a bad [ __ ] that can see but
I also have chronic dry eye was it worth
it
definitely but let me know would you do
it I'll drop it
does anyone had the surgery she's saying
no she's saying because she got the
surgery she has Chronicles oh is it and
my mine is because I had the surgery
years I mean
15 20 years ago my uh the side effect
for me after time so when I drive at
night the lights are like Blurry like
starred like everything Stars I've been
driving sometime like damn this Vlog is
crazy
it might not be the surgery that caused
that could be the could be the CT
splashing up yeah it could be like
they're getting hit in the head so
viciously I like glasses though I think
glasses are okay I'm a glasses guy yeah
no [ __ ] this guy's blind as [ __ ] too
he's just like he's over here fake with
his contacts you know are you in
contacts yeah yeah why you were seeing
with his glasses ridiculous it looks
like he's bad yeah my dad but also you
can see much better with contacts than
you can with glasses
you think so yeah the doctor I mean
because I have both and when I put my
glasses on it's not as sharp and I went
to the eye doctor I'm like why
why is it not a sharp it's the same uh
prescription and he's like because when
it's on your eye it's just better my dad
had the surgery so now I can't even I
would use that I like glasses I love
LASIK surgery like a week ago but uh his
mom died my grandma died and he had to
do like all the speaking thing and for
whatever reason you have it now they
give you the glasses like Steven Seagal
looks like he looked ridiculous can you
take the glasses off refuse to
no it's not because you can't see it's
because something has something to do
with like bacteria or something get in
there for like the first week oh wow so
they're like [ __ ]
Bono from YouTube oh really oh like
you're freaking like in a swimming pool
yeah
he looks so dope talking at the [ __ ]
giving the eulogy
sup bro my bad yeah
what's up guys he goes you know he's
nervous to speak he goes Gone Too Soon
my dad's one of 11. I'm really close to
my uncles and aunts I look at that one
too soon she was 98. yeah yeah 90. take
the queen
you don't want to die the same week as
the queen though I mean it just
overshadows it I mean I mean you know go
out 12 Days by the way speaking at least
like R.I.P David Arnold yeah you know
what I mean 50. he would be five or
something he'd be upset knowing that the
queen took his Thunder you know she
overshadowed everything yeah the People
are funny like yeah good she deserves it
deserves it she was nice she wrote a
letter to the people of I don't know if
it was New Zealand or someplace that the
British British people of like and then
and she said please open this in like
2086
or something like that they just opened
it and they just opened it I would open
it now
did they open it in there that's what I
think you know what's funny is they're
like the voice
family they're not even British
what are they none of them British she's
German I think or some [ __ ] well they're
all [ __ ] inbred and German and bread
you're so weird imagine you know that
this is they're still a part of a lot of
fact let's bring it up don't they go
back to like you know like there's been
like 75 million shows about Queen
Elizabeth yeah oh the ground you know
there's so many of them every year they
seem to make one a new one about the
same story I'm sorry did you like the
crown or no I finished the tutors well
Crown's [ __ ] dope uh House of dragons
what's up Daddy yeah
they kind of like they went
yeah but it's you know what I I just do
find it ridiculous that
that you know she's having kids and her
husband is a black dude with blonde hair
and none of her kids look like that it's
like you don't think we gonna know we
know how to go sometimes those babies
are lighter skin still are you not happy
that that the richest dude in the
Kingdom's the black guy
glad to make you happy it's not about
that I'm just saying it's about it's
about like the the daughter whatever her
name is how she's like so Brazen with
her Affair you know what I mean just
braids you don't watch it huh
no but I finished the tutors
it's not that good
I've watched the whole [ __ ] thing
you've never seen the crown I'm never
gonna answer three million dollars I
haven't answered it and I'm never gonna
answer it that's just gonna be one of
those things I'll never answer
I never seen it you're lost I've never
seen it you're lost handmaid's tale are
you watching that I stopped watching
it's just depressing it's like nobody oh
my God the thing about my handmade sauce
that drives me nuts is
you'll hear people in the world be like
it's because we're living in handmaid's
tale and you're like this is enough what
are you [ __ ] talking about dude this
is nothing like that [ __ ] handmade
sale I watch a [ __ ] and it's well not
here in this country
white chicks at Starbucks saying this
[ __ ] yeah no
um yeah but you see what just happened
in Iran you know they killed this girl
and now they're like fine they're like
revolting and they're burning their
burkas and all that kind of stuff now
you want to move there yeah me I don't
want to move to Iran it's [ __ ] I mean
that's just awesome that's what cut to
burning with some dates yeah
I'm gonna be in Lakeland Florida and
then I'm then we're taking a thick crew
to [ __ ] Iran
[Applause]
so come see me there and check me out on
Twitch Eric Griffin gaming Oxnard I'll
see you Oxnard I'll see you Saturday
I'll be in Peoria I'll be in Savannah
and I'll be in Raleigh and um wait
there's another one Tempe I don't feel
nice [ __ ] yes it would be cool if like a
big dude
I like that
I'm in Boston this Thursday Friday
Saturday last Boston almost sold out if
it sells out by Wednesday I had a show
on Saturday
um and then San Jose is October 13th
through the 15th San Jose Improv Salt
Lake City October 20th through the 22nd
one of my favorite clubs Wise Guys shout
out to Keith and then I end October in
Calgary Canada I'm coming up eh Calgary
is October 27th at the rooftop downtown
Calgary that thing's almost sold out so
we're gonna add a show on the 28th so
get your tickets for either that
Thursday or Friday tickets to
thickboy.com love you guys man thanks
for tuning in guys thank you
[Music]
how many times I gotta make this song
Wait I get the gist I just probably have
to slow it down and hit it like this
[Music]
hold on wait a minute let me think it's
the king and the sting in the way let's
go legendary